michael j fox found out that he had
parkinson's when he was just 29 years
old
that means he has lived more than half
his life with this debilitating disease
and
while his courageous fight has inspired
so many michael admits a recent threat
to his health
was nearly too much to bear
[Music]
i had parkinson's for 30 years so i was
kind of used to that and then i had a
tumor on my spine and i had that
operator on it was pretty severe it was
if it didn't get fixed it was going to
lead to paralysis but i had to learn to
walk again i had to learn to
literally to put one foot in front of
the other michael opens up for the first
time about the high risk
surgery he had in 2018 and the
devastating aftermath
i was thought i was healed i thought i
got walking down and i was
all ready to go and i was strutting down
the hallway in my
my apartment i was alone and i fell in
the kitchen and i shattered my arm
the arm was just one insult too many and
i
found myself really questioning this
kind of lifelong
uh dedication to optimism and and
and belief in and that everything turns
out great and
and i thought who am i to tell people
that i'm lying here in the floor in the
kitchen waiting for the amulets to come
with my arm and i'm and i'm not happy
the beloved family thai star recounts
his darkest hours in his new book
no time like the future from his
struggles with alcoholism to his
parkinson's diagnosis in 1991
he says writing his fourth book was
cathartic
struggling with acting in the last
couple jobs i had it just wasn't
satisfying to me
because i couldn't do the level of work
i wanted to do and
and so i started to write and and and i
found myself
able to express myself in ways that they
were similar to acting
michael turns 60 next year but this year
he's celebrating the 20th anniversary of
the michael j
fox foundation having raised over a
billion dollars for parkinson's research
ever humble michael doesn't take any of
the credit as we get the job done not
only
did he even credit me doorman
listen we have so much more with michael
you know he opened up about his marriage
and what he says about his wife tracy
let me just say this it's very emotional
have your tissue ready tomorrow
listen i'm over here already welling up
just thinking about it